how do I get better at chess I mean that
question along with whatever happened to
Bobby Fischer probably like the two
questions I get the most and I've
traveled all over the world so the
answer to how do I get better at chess
is actually really compellingly easy
what I did as a beginning player and it
was a I was lucky I basically fell into
the answer let's put it that way maybe I
was encouraged by some of my earlier
coaches I'm not too sure but whatever
the reason I did or found this method
I've always been very happy to share it
and that is I wrote things down
really I just wrote things down and when
I say things I'm specifically talking
about analysis okay
I wrote my analysis down when lose draw
didn't matter
I took the game score put it in my
notebook and I wrote it down today it's
like everybody types it in and uses the
Houdini or whatever chess engine they
may have on their computer to go over
the game and while that is actually a
great tool I first what I tried to do
was when I wrote my analysis down I
tried to capture what I was thinking in
the game right like yes or why did you
play this move oh I wanted to play that
because I had this concept in mind
whether my concept was good or bad
didn't matter what I was trying to do
was literally flash record my thoughts
so my first step in writing things down
was writing down what I was thinking
about
I plate in other words I've trying to
remember exactly my thought process so
that was step one then step two is I
then took my game score sheet as well as
my analysis and try to work with my
buddy's friends coaches whatever have
you and I showed them what I how I
played what I thought and then they
would say that idea a good idea right
you know wrong did you consider this did
you consider that and I would write that
down so here we have a tournament very
nice tournament I mean International
Master and Grand Master norms going on
right above us as we speak and a number
of the players in the tournament are
actually on the Lindenwood University
chess team
well the st. Louis chess club has made
an obligation to the Lindenwood chess
team to provide coaching well it just so
happens look this is perfect they create
the content I go over and analyze the
games with them and they sit there and
say well I wanted to do this I wanted to
do that and I said well did you consider
this in other words your typical post
mortem not at the writing down the
analysis mind you but it was something I
endeavoured to do so when people ask me
well how do I get better at chess very
very simple answer write down your
thoughts
write down your analysis you cannot go
wrong and it's the easiest most powerful
tool that I can recommend write down
your analysis the game I'm about to show
you tonight is it was played eight
ancient different life time years and
years and years ago but it's one of
those games that is very typically chess
mystifying
it's a mystifying game a strange game
and when we're in the game I'm about to
show you this is a good this is a game
where it's going to be very interactive
Michael at
before the lecture began will this be an
interactive oh yes yes yes yes I want
your participation because for the first
first and foremost because when I say
this game is mystifying I really mean
that and today I'm still mystified so
any feedback that I can get from the
audience to give me a greater insight
into the game is most welcome and it's a
game I played like so you know you're in
trouble when your lecturer is sitting
there saying gosh I don't get it either
right but guess what that happens a lot
and in the games that I've been
analyzing both players come out of the
game and said you need to do what
happened okay did I miss a win I thought
I was worse and I thought my opponent
mr. win and vice versa
the players are oftentimes confused well
this is a very confusing game and that's
a setup so let's see what it is about
this game that I found mystifying and
hopefully you'll be able to explain to
me what was going on as I'll do my best
to explain to you what was going on
first of all I was black so I don't know
if you want to set up the black pieces
in front of you and this was you know I
was 18 1978 as 18 years old and my
opponent is like the highest rated
player I've ever played up into this
time now keep in mind I started in 1972
so I had six years of experience and not
just six years of tournament experience
and blitz experience but I mean I was a
played a lot of a lot of chess so I was
so to speak a veteran chess player but
my opponent was one of the highest rated
players in the world at the time he's
definitely in the top ten and his name
is Yan Timman from holland grandmaster
from holland you probably know that in
1993 for example
when garry kasparov and Nigel short
broke away from fee day to play their
World Championship outside of feed a fee
they staged a World Championship match
for the vacant crown between Anatoly
Karpov and yon Tim OTT and that was in
1993 and 1978 yattaman was one of the
highest-rated players in the world here
we were we're playing in Lone Pine
California in the famous Lewis statham
Memorial Tournament Lewis Statham
tournaments of Lone Pine California it's
round one you know and somehow I was
just at that bubble where I played the
highest rated guy in the tournament
right and my opponent opened efore okay
well in those days and still today I had
a kind of a mixed mixture of what what
defense I might choose a caro-kann a
perk defense a French defense a Russian
defense what we call Petrov and so forth
and so on
I chose for this game the French defense
and we get a very very standard position
the winner were French defense and in
those days I was really strongly under
the influence of Tigran Petrosian and
how many of you are familiar with Tegan
petrosyan and you know who I mean wow
that guy just played a totally unique
brand of chess which you know I couldn't
possibly duplicate but I liked his play
I was very inspired by his play and one
of tigran's favorite moves is this can
credibly crazy move like Queen d7 here
and that was a move I played of course
c5 attacking white in the center as well
as 97 have been played a thousand times
and before this move is played
the French defense is a great defense I
like it very much and as we all
understand the French defense has a
drawback these two pawns in the middle
of the board can find this Bishop on CA
and one of the crucial things for the
black player to do is to seek to resolve
what we call the bad Bishop how in the
world this last move which really looks
contradictory help solve this Bishop
well in fact it doesn't I mean it
doesn't not in the short term basically
one of the things that can go on in this
opening is that after ninety seven which
is the standard move let me just put it
that way
ninety seven a three Bishop takes c3
check B takes c3 c5 one of the one of
the ideas for the white player is to
play Queen to g4 quite quickly and to
capture this pawn on g7 the pawn on g7
is weak because the dark squared Bishop
is missing okay so far so good we're
kind of getting a feeling for what's
going on Queen d7 so now that we
understand that there's a potential for
Queen g4 and Queen takes g7 we see that
the Queen on d7 could potentially defend
the pawn on g7 so for example in case of
a move like Queen g4 yes sir
yeah that's likely the Google after
exactly so after for example queen g4
there's the visit what Black has two
ideas one idea is to play f5 and you
know we all understand the discovered
attack right discovered attack one of
the great tactics of in chess history
but how about the discovered defense
that's kind of like oh what this is
right hey you know it discovered defense
I attack you and I defend and if you
capture my pawn alpha saw thank you very
much I'll win the tempo back with Knight
takes f6 and as Michael was saying let's
go back a moment if white were to play a
three here one possibility for black is
that this Queen on d7 could potentially
go to c6 where its axis pawn or
potentially go to Queen a4 to try to
stop this standard French idea of a form
Bishop a3 on this diagonal by blocking
so it's a kind of a multi-faceted move
but it goes a little bit deeper than
that okay what happened in the game
Bishop d2 b6 and this is this is the
real intention of black black wants to
simply play Bishop to a6 get rid of this
problem Bishop trade it for White's
bishop on f1 and because the queen is on
d7 if the Queen wasn't on d7 there would
be this annoying Bishop b5 c6 the bishop
could potentially come back to a4 and
avoid the trade
okay so b6 so this was all standard
stuff Knight f3 and now
you know we've got a kind of a standard
position we're all very happy and out of
the blue I play Bishop f8 so if white is
angered or mystified or otherwise about
my queen coming to d7
he's really now angry
seriously angry that I'm breaking all
the rules with this move Bishop f8 like
what the heck am i doing I told you it's
going to be a mystifying kind of a game
right so what is the idea Bishop f8 well
in the first place
literally I don't want to trade my
bishop for his Knight and I want to keep
the dark squared Bishop why do I want to
do that well I want to do that because
these two pawns in the middle of the
board are on dark squares and I I'm
basically saying to white that you I
have a problem Bishop thanks to these
two guys but you have a problem bishop
thanks to these two guys so I want to
keep dark square Bishop saan the board
and I'm willing to lose time in the
opening to do this and the only reason I
can get away with this by the way is
because the positions closed if the
position was open losing time in this
style that I'm about to show you would
really be a suicidal way of playing
there's another point kind of a we all
understand that my concept is I want to
play Bishop a6 but I really want white
to move his Bishop I don't want him to
play bishop trades oh I want him to
first move his Bishop to e2 I won't I
want to extract a tempo from white so
instead of putting my Bishop on e7
and trying to develop my night to H sex
where it could be captured I'm keeping
the e7 vague square vacant so that I can
bring my knight to e7 and my Knight to
f5 let's see how things develop Bishop
e2 Bishop a6 castles Knight to e7 Bishop
takes a six-night takes a six Queen e2
attacking my knight Knight to b8 now
just some thoughts that I'd like to
extract from you my audience and to tell
me what you think
I mean first of all if you were right
it's what if you were right if you were
white you got to say you're pretty happy
with White's position correct
I mean you've castled you have more than
your fair share of the center you
control more space you're much better
developed your rooks are already
connected look at blacks pieces blacks
rooks aren't connected his King is weird
and you would say and I think rightly so
that you would much prefer to have
White's position is there anybody who
doubts that white has an advantage
because there's nothing to question
right white has an advantage however
having an advantage yes
well true enough I do have a solid
position but I'm significantly behind in
development and well that's the issue
you know like okay white has an
advantage but how how should he increase
his advantage suggestions know how
should white how should white White's on
the move here how should white increase
his advantage
bingo try exactly so that's the key
answer to take advantage of his superior
development white needs to open up the
position excellent now we've got the
concept how do we do that how do how
does wide open up the position what
should he do to open up the position
please okay so this Knight jumps into
the air and then to play c4 okay so
everybody kind of like that idea that
the knight should maybe move away from
the c3 square now keep in mind this is
one of the best players in the world I'm
up against here so like you know who
like let's try to guess and ferment what
his ideas are now imagine this Knight
goes away and then then your next move
with c4 and then I would take it capture
it wouldn't my knight end up on a very
nice square on d5 right so in other
words this guy we remove this guy from
the board remove this guy from the board
and guess what this Knight would have a
nice square so your concept is
absolutely right the knight has to move
away from the c3 square but it has to be
able to confront
the night coming to d5 because the night
being on d5 would be a very strong piece
right centralized and protect it so two
choices night to b5 as Michael suggested
is one choice and what's a second
I do you want okay so night 95 I think I
would simply have played a six and push
the night away and then the night would
have ended up stepping on a silly square
night a three so for example just to be
clear let's imagine 95 a new variation a
six let's say night would end up on this
silly square and then I could play
Knight f5 and try to capture this night
double up the guys pawns
okay so yon Tim on Knight d1 and so if I
sit on my hands if I don't do anything
why it's going to play Knight to e3 c-4
open up the position better development
bang bang bang sign my score sheet
thanks for playing
so c5 confronting white by attacking
light in the center okay so it seems to
me that white has a choice you can
capture this pawn and after recapture
play c4 or he could try to play c4 right
away I mean I think what yon really
wanted was for me to do nothing then
play Knight e3 and then play c4 so I
immediately attack white in the center
again this is several choices here
Knight e3 I would capture Knight
captures Knight comes to F sit and
Knight comes to c6 attacking the pawn on
e3 and maybe the night on e3 isn't
exactly on the best square so what yon
did was he captured
again he had some serious choices and I
recaptured and he played c4 and I
definitely didn't want Yan to open up
the position further so I played d4
shutting down the position trying to
keep the position closed because
obviously white superior development is
going to kill me okay so a different
approach to this position now suddenly
and you know like with each pawn move
the position has changed and now white
needs a rethink about the position give
me some ideas what if you were white in
this exact position what thoughts would
be going through your mind yes sir b2 b4
is an excellent excellent idea because
the idea behind the move be for several
fold first of all you want to attack
this pawn on d4 so by playing before you
undermine the protection of the pawn
secondly you want to open up the
position very very nice concept and
thirdly you'll notice that maybe your
Knights not so happy on d1 so this move
be for an excellent move gives you the
idea of perhaps playing Knight v2 to d3
but let's see how things would work out
in case b4 was played oops
huh now escape cancel let's do that one
again
okay so b4 new variation as you can tell
whenever we play a new variation those
moves won't play do I give you an
insight okay so first point is I can see
you're a very clever guy you want to
take my pawn you want to maybe somehow
try to influence me
capturing my pawn on d4 but I'm equally
clever I'm going to move my knight away
so in case you end up trading pawns then
after Bishop takes what my idea is as
I'm going to try to do my best to attack
your pawn on e5 so let's see how things
might develop from this kind of a
situation okay well in the first place
you know I got to Pat myself on the back
before I was getting killed in
development slowly slowly
as black now I'm kind of catching up as
soon as I can so guess what my rooks
will be connected and I'm no longer you
know significantly behind in time if you
pursue the attack with the move c4 c5
I'll drop my bishop back to c7 and I'll
keep continual continuous pressure
against the pawn on e5 it's hard to say
that white has a significant advantage
yeah okay a very good suggestion but it
doesn't lead to an advantage for white
another ideas besides the move b4
brilliant and really in suggestion guy
let me repeat what the gentleman just
said your name sir Lauren what Lauren
just suggested if is wouldn't it be
beautiful if white could put his pawn on
f2 to f4
then this night just as a concept mind
you this night on d1 could come to f2
perhaps to the e4 square perhaps to the
d3 square so in other words as a means
of activating this Knight this pawn is
in the way sorry you're going to
continue yes nice for
I sorry so for example instead of the
move c4 you mean Knight just dy aha okay
so in this position for example one of
the things one of the suggestions Lauren
was having is what about Knight to e1
okay so we understand what you're saying
is that what you would like to do is
advance your pawn to f4 claim more space
you know go kill kill the rabbit you
know let's get the guy okay concept when
you play the move f4 do you hear this
fellow do you hear I'm kind of crying
and saying if you if you're given a
thought about me you you close the
diagonal a bit second second thing is
your night retreat as good or is
well-intentioned as it might be
it does temporarily leave the pawn on d4
unprotected and I may take advantage of
that absence to play Knight here and
attack the pawn now as we see it saw in
the game one of the one of the
advantages that Yann managed to achieve
with his maneuver that he did is he
provoked my pawn to come to d4 in other
words when my night which is planning
become dat not by would note doesn't
have the Square D for Vale because it's
occupied but Lauren who has made a
brilliant insight into the position
young Tim on one of the best players in
the world
same concept now you know Here I am you
know I'm onboard one I'm the rookie guy
you know I'm like wow you know you know
what you know what creativity what
genius these top grandmasters of the
world do you know bringing your back to
the first rank you know like I'm in awe
you know like okay but now now it starts
to the the the chapters the mystery is
being unfolded before my eyes and I can
see exactly where white is going and the
more I look in the position the more
beautiful it appears to me that whites
position is given a free hand yan
intends to play Knight to d3 beautiful
blockading light we all appreciate such
blockading Knights correct which will
attack the pawn on c5 which will make
future ideas of B to be for that much
easier he's going to play Knight here is
going to move his pawn to f4 is going to
move this Knight which is sitting on d1
to f2 you'll move it from f2 to e4 and
the combination of these Beautiful's you
know it's just like a mosaic is a
beautiful castle being built and all of
whites pieces are going to be ideally
placed and if we mentally imagine one
night one white night here one white
night here guess what
the c5 pawn is toast and if this c5 pawn
ever falls then the whole black center
collapses and you know once again sign
my score sheet thank you for coming okay
well it's all it's genius it's great
it's great
I played h5
like you know whites building this
marvelous tapestry and it's like I don't
know what's going on so I'll just make
another stupid move
you know but help me out
is this a stupid move yes no big ok
that's not exactly the answer I was
looking for but right precisely Michael
I wanted to keep this outpost my
intention my my intention was to bring
my Knight to f5 but I don't want to get
booted away I want to keep my home safe
and secure on f5 and I don't want to
have to face g2g for no I did this I
mean it was like okay maybe we were both
in our own separate worlds but at least
we understood what I was doing in Italy
so I played at five he played Knight d3
attacking my pawn on c5 I played Knight
f5 defending my pawn on c5 he played f4
and now again things are unfolding very
very smoothly we can see that if White
has two moves bringing his Knight to e4
is basically going to put so much
intense pressure on c5 I'm going to have
a real problem okay
so any guesses as to what I did yes sir
and to do that how would I go about
right so I put my knight on a six but
Santa's not going to be very happy
that's like a naughty night I mean it's
not really really really working is it
okay let's see what I did queen bee
seven making room for the night
yeah so I can so the night on a six will
be a little bit offsides the night on D
seven will defend the pawn on c5 and be
a little bit more in the center yeah
simultaneously by the way somebody I
think it was you I'm you kind of
mentioned that maybe I could push the H
pawn right well because this Queen kind
of looks down on this pawn on d2 and
there's the outside possibility that a
queen on b7 could come in its own night
here Knight here now very very
interesting unfoldment and again it's
sort of like both players are pursuing
their respective strategic goals and
again I'd like to pause at this time and
kind of weigh the scales take a poll you
know
tabulate things how how would you rate
White's play as it been good do you like
do you like White's position not as
better okay got some head nods don't be
you know right and but I mean whites
played okay blacks played okay I still
thought that white had an advantage and
one of the things that was going through
Yuans mind
was that if he brought his knight
immediately to e4 let's suggest 94 one
of the things he didn't particularly
like was that I might play a move like
93 with the idea Bishop takes c3 Queen
takes e4 of course Knight III would not
be a good move why because tell me how
it lose it what would you do if you were
white if you play Bishop takes e3 I'll
play Queen takes e4 and sir yes Knight
d6 check and deed forces of the trade
but keep in mind at the end of the day
the rook on f3 is hanging the White has
a real nasty move here to defend the
knight on e4 and threaten a discovery
yes sir yes both nights do indeed attack
the c5 pawn but they there's one to
attack one to defenders so unfortunately
you can't capture this pawn on c4 c5 as
much as I know you'd like to at the
moment though your knight on e4 is
hanging yes sir yeah exactly Queen to f3
is a nasty response it threatens to move
the knight to either the d6 or the f6
square with check capture my queen if I
defend my queen then you've got time to
win your pawn with Bishop tags III so I
thought that after the move Knight e4
that white was doing well the reason
that Tim on did not play Knight e4 is he
was a little bit concerned that what
would happen if I played the move rook
b8 protecting my queen and setting
myself up for this incursion with 93 so
what he decided to do he thought it
would be in his best interest to first
trade the Queen's off the board so Queen
takes Knight takes and the more I looked
at this position the more I appreciated
what Yan was trying to do and again
let's do our best to try to sum up what
is going on here in the position could
somebody explain to me what blacks and
blacks advantage in the position might
be what are some of blacks pluses as far
as I can tell there's only two of them
the half-open be file but man that's
neither here there I mean the B file he
can close it and then not a not too much
activity the thinking of two advantages
being go that's number one
this strategic this night is very well
placed on f5 number two bingo
protected pass Pau those are the only
two advantages that I have and while I
was sitting here thinking now what do I
do a thought came into my mind that
scared me if I only have these two
advantages this guy in this guy one of
the things that white might do is try to
rob me bastard robbed me of one of my
advantages the night on f5 in my mind I
started to be worried about the idea of
king F 2 G 3 h3 looks very slow King up
to g3
h3 but once white gets g4 in you know my
knight will have to go back and when it
goes back well you know other bad things
might happen I might get rolled away so
this going into this middle game /
endgame by trading Queens
I thought was a very clever idea of yan
because he makes this idea of expanding
on the kingside more possible now that
the queens are off the board his queen
my queen kind of keeps him honest he
doesn't want to blow open the position
on the King side with the Queen's on the
board but once the Queens are off the
board hey he's more than willing to go
for it
you